[Music]
in our consideration of the
architectural imagination there were two
primary points first of all the
imagination is productive it constructs
schema that from since data that it
presents to the understanding so so the
imagination which is part of the
subjective realm is productive the
imagination doesn't actually produce
knowledge it's not it doesn't deal with
concepts but it sets us on the path to
knowledge now what we have there is a
very powerful model for aesthetic
experience but there's a serious
omission and that is that is that on
this model architecture doesn't have a
history esthetics doesn't have a history
we owe the conceptualization and the
model for a philosophy of art history to
the German idealist philosopher Hegel in
aesthetic experience we have to
distinguish between aesthetic pleasure
let's say and truth Hegel is after a
model where art deals with truth that
art discloses truths about the world by
giving those truths appearance and art
in its highest vocation is an art in
which the truth of beings that is to say
of individuals but also being as a whole
that that is the uncondition the
absolute the totality in which that
being opens itself up it appears and its
historical existence is made manifest
through art now another way of saying
this is that cultures learn about
themselves through their art they learn
about their objectives they learn about
how they function
they cultures represent themselves to
themselves through their art and what
Hegel imagines
is that all the cultures through time
can and all of the epochs of art can be
a symbol together in this giant global
mechanism Hegel is a very systematic
philosopher and he wants a total system
a mechanism that gathers up all the
cultures and all the epochs of art into
a single coherent unified system now the
idea that architecture should be thought
of as having a history is itself a
historical accomplishment Hegel riding
in the 19th century earlier philosophers
writing in the 18th century they gave us
the concept that architecture has a
history before that we had manuals of
building we had treatises that told us
theories about building we had
biographies of artists but we didn't
have history as such I mean why should
it be that architecture is in the flux
of history I mean why don't we just have
buildings and we and we and we and we
refine how we make those buildings and
we keep making the same kind of building
until we get the building as best that
it can be why should why instead of that
should should we think that architecture
has to progress that architecture has to
change but more important how can it be
that architecture and art generally is
involved with thought not not how can we
think about architecture but how can
architecture be thought like what what
involves what that involves and we owe
this also to Hegel
is a very special relationship of
subject to object in our earlier model
the subject was dominant the subject is
productive the imagination is
constructing its reality Hegel who is
concerned with the truth of art wants
the object to push back he wants the
subject to react to the object the
subject being the categories the
interpretations the way we are in the
world he wants the subjective realm to
react back to the object so the object
takes on a
more primary role and therefore the
subject can no truths about the object
truths about the world because the
subject makes those truths appear